Maybe you have the stereotype that women don't like hockey. Well I'm here to be
the exception to the rule for your stereotype, because I love hockey. Wait, let
me clarify that. I'm a Detroit Red Wings fan. That's right, I have only one
team that I'm in favor of, and that's the Detroit Red Wings. Now when I was
living in Michigan in the Detroit area, I would run into other Red Wings fans
all the time. Everywhere we went somebody had on a t-shirt, they had on their
hats. They had on their jerseys. And it was awesome. But now that we're talking
about the Red Wings, that's going to bring us to our next topic. Let me set the
scene. Throughout the years as a Red Wings fan I've had the great opportunity
to watch my team win multiple Stanley Cup championships, and it's been awesome.
And throughout those years we've also seen a few pesky teams that prevented my
team from moving forward in the playoffs. One of those teams was the San Jose
Sharks. Now, I really had no opinion of them other than that they were a team
that sometimes got in the way. Fast-forward a few years and I find myself
living in enemy territory with the San Jose Sharks and their fans. It turns
out, unfortunately, that a lot of the fans don't like the Red Wings, or Red
Wings fans. Now, how do I know that? I know because I've experienced first hand
what it's like to be treated as an outsider. I'll never forget the time when I
finished teaching my general psychology course, ran down to my office, and put
on my Wings gear, and went down to catch the bus to watch the game. I got on
the bus, and I realized that I was in a sea of teal, all Sharks fans. And
immediately they all started booing me. Some people had some off color remarks
about my team. And they were yelling me go back to Detroit. Well, I can tell
you from that experience it was obvious that I was a part of the out group, and
not a part of the in group. As you can imagine, the bus ride was a little
uncomfortable. There were a few people who were kind of nice to me. I think
they felt badly because I was getting picked on, but for the majority of the
ride people were booing me. Here's the interesting part. When I got to the
arena I saw a lot of Detroit Red Wings fans. They were wearing their jerseys,
had their hats on, and we smiled at each other, we high five. We yelled, go
wings, and here I had total strangers, but I felt a part of that in-group. And
I did not feel a part of the San Jose Sharks, that would be the out-group.